[Aplausos]
queria começar minha apresentação
fazendo uma pergunta quantos aqui
gostariam ou já fizeram em algum momento
crescer mais rápido na sua carreira eu
atingiu o sucesso profissional de forma
mais rápida
vou fazer uma conta que a galera do
fundo só aqui do lado
então hoje na platéia o estilo que
aproximadamente 70 e 4,3 por cento das
pessoas já quiseram querem crescer mais
rápido na carreira no profissionalmente
isso é muito comum quando a gente pensa
no dia dos dias de hoje em que é a gente
está vivendo em um mundo hiperconectado
em que as coisas acontecem cada vez mais
rápido a gente tem qualquer informação a
uma distância de um clique
a gente pode fazer qualquer pergunta
para o google que ele vai responder
a gente fica com raiva ou sem paciência
quando o bê demora mais de cinco minutos
a gente quer que ele seja instantâneo
isso vem mudando isso vai acontecendo
cada vez mais
mas quando a gente fala da nossa
profissão quando a gente fala da nossa
carreira
a gente não pode ter pressa gente a
gente precisa esperar porque as coisas
boas precisam de tempo para amadurecer
às vezes a gente pensa em um objetivo a
gente quer muito algo profissionalmente
ea gente acha que é simples a gente
chegar lá a gente precisa apenas cumprir
algumas etapas passar por alguns dar
alguns passos específicos que a gente
conseguir atingir seu objetivo
então por exemplo se você quer ser um
sócio de um escritório de advocacia
você primeiro faz a faculdade de direito
depois se consegue um estágio na área
no escritório você faz uma pode faz o
ambiente trabalha duro e você chega lá
só que a verdade gente é que no meio do
caminho um monte de coisas acontecem
coisas novas e inesperadas que você não
tinha como prever inicialmente inclusive
o seu objetivo
nem pode mudar eu queria compartilhar um
pouco com vocês na minha trajetória para
vocês entenderem também é como isso
aconteceu pra mim
tudo começou quando eu fazia faculdade
ainda era universitário fazer a
faculdade de economia e eu te sonhava em
fazer uma carreira é uma carreira de
sucesso no mercado financeiro
eu vi os filmes e os livros abre o
jornal e vi as notícias e aquilo me
encantava
eu achava que eu poderia crescer
rapidamente participar de grandes
projetos e atingiu o sucesso e ter uma
boa remuneração bom salário é pra com os
pais nesse pra ir pra esse caminho por
esse caminho primeira coisa que eu fiz
foi conseguir um estágio em um banco não
era exatamente o que eu queria por fazer
muito trabalho operacional e de controle
mas eu consegui aprender algumas coisas
sobre operações financeiras e tal e aí
depois alguns tempo de algum tempo eu
sabia que esse estádio não ia me
proporcionar o crescimento que eu queria
e eu continuarei buscando e até que
dentro de alguns meses eu consegui um
outro estágio aí sim na área de
investimentos
foi a primeira vez que eu pude provar um
pouquinho desse meu objetivo
profissional e ali eu de fato lidava com
os investimentos
eu avaliava os novos investimentos que
seriam boas opções podem sim para serem
feitos analisavam mercado a economia
como estava funcionando e acompanhava os
investimentos que já tinham sido feitos
e vias estavam gerando bons ganhos
aprendi muito conheci muita gente desse
mercado
eu tive acesso a muito conteúdo que eu
não tinha eu aprendi muito e foi algo
super reconhecedores pra mim mas eu
também conheci um outro lado que até
então pra mim era pouco falado pouco
conhecido
esse lado é um lado mais negativo que
por esses mercados ser um mercado super
volúvel ele volátil ele variava muito de
acordo com as notícias que vão
acontecendo no dia a dia
então desde uma guerra do outro lado do
mundo até uma mudança de políticos ou
então
uma descoberta ou algo novo que
aconteceu e que podia mudar tudo aquilo
que você vinha construindo durante muito
tempo
além disso algumas pessoas sabiam dessa
volatilidade e ela se aproveitavam para
lançar notícias que fariam mercado
variar também assim elas teriam ganhos
ou provocaram perdas de outras pessoas
o que eu percebi é que muitas pessoas
que trabalhavam nesse mercado
acabavam tendo ficando muito ansiosas
essas pessoas elas dormiam pensando em
notícias inúmeros e elas acordavam
pensão de notícias números e foi aí que
eu percebi que isso era algo que eu não
gostaria que eu não queria para minha
vida para sempre
então foi o primeiro foi o primeiro
momento que meu objetivo profissional
estava mudando eu percebi que eu poderia
atingir aquilo que eu queria um
crescimento participar de grandes
projetos fazer algo relevante fazer a
diferença mas não necessariamente
precisa crescer no mercado financeiro
poderia fazer isso em qualquer outro
mercado
e aí eu mudei meu objetivo profissional
pela primeira vez ao invés de uma
carreira de sucesso no mercado
financeiro eu busquei uma carreira de
sucesso ea partir do momento que eu
tiver essa consciência as coisas
começaram a mudar também
eu tive a oportunidade de fazer um
processo seletivo para uma consultoria
que o ajudaria as empresas que queriam
se aventurar no mercado financeiro
eu não estaria mais dentro mas já
estaria ajudando essas empresas
eu fui até a última etapa mas eu não
passei aquilo me frustrou muito nesse
momento porque era um lugar naquele
história e me dará a oportunidade de
desenvolver várias habilidades e várias
competências que ainda não tinha eu
continuei trabalhando como um na área de
investimentos como estagiário até que
alguns meses depois pelo meu bom
desempenho nessa nessa nesse processo eu
fui convidado para fazer parte da equipe
da consulta da mesma consultoria
só que pra atuar em outra área eu
comecei a ajudar não empresas queriam se
aventurar no mercado financeiro mas
qualquer tipo de empresa que gostaria de
resolver seus problemas
então desde uma empresa que gostaria de
reduzir riscos até
é melhorar seus processos internos e
reduzir custos
enfim eu estarei ajudando essas pessoas
essas empresas e lá foi também uma época
muito boa eu aprendi muito e lá eu
fiquei durante vários anos e eu ganhei
foi onde eu ganhei maturidade
profissional foi não conseguir ganhar
maturidade profissional
apesar de estar fazendo algo que eu não
imaginava lá atrás quando pensava no
mercado financeiro
nesse momento eu também percebi que
tinha uma coisa que eu gostava muito de
fazer que eu gostaria muito de fazer o
que era ter o meu próprio negócio
então meu objetivo profissional mudava
mais uma vez e eu tentava conectar
aquilo que eu estava aprendendo no dia a
dia com novos projetos que eu estaria
lançando o primeiro projeto que eu
lancei foi um projeto de turismo
eu achava que eu poderia oferecer uma
experiência melhor para quem estava
viajando e eu queria ajudar essa pessoa
a fazer um planejamento melhor da sua
viagem desde o momento que ela reserva
havia o avião o vôo até o passeio que
ela vai fazer no segundo dia da viagem
dela pela manhã por exemplo e foi uma
experiência nova completamente nova para
mim e eu tive muita dificuldade era
muito difícil de achar material de
qualidade que me ajudasse
estava tudo muito solto muito espalhado
e além disso alguns amigos ela me
perguntava mendonça já têm computador
você tem cnpj
eu falava assim sem que isso como assim
então eu percebi como é difícil para os
novos empreendedores começarem os seus
negócios a partir daí eu decidi mudar o
projeto ea gente começou a tentar ajudar
esses novos empreendedores também
tirarem suas idéias do papel
a idéia era construir uma rede onde os
empreendedores pudessem trocar
informações e conversar entre si se
ajudarem para chegar mais longe de
chegar até onde eles queriam e aí nesse
projeto a gente já foi bem mais longe a
gente tinha passado por vários
aprendizado já no primeiro projeto que
ajudaram a gente no segundo então a
gente conseguiu um sócio desenvolvedor
por exemplo a gente conversou com muitos
empreendedores muito
os investidores e ea gente recebeu muito
feedback sobre o projeto muito
interessante mas em determinado momento
eu vi que eu precisaria ou largar a
minha carreira como consultor e focar no
projeto porque eu precisaria fazer um
desenvolvimento pesado ou a gente
precisaria colocar uma grana que a gente
não tinha
então esse projeto foi parar na gaveta
também nesse momento além de estar
tocando o projeto e está trabalhando
como consultor
eu fui percebendo que eu gostava não eu
gostava muito de ajudar as pessoas que
gostariam de se desenvolver
profissionalmente seja um empreendedor
ou seja o cara que trabalhava comigo na
consultoria e eu e foi ficando mais
claro para mim a cada dia que passava
que eu gostaria não apenas de empreender
mas também que gostaria de aprender com
a educação é algo que me traria muita
satisfação pessoal e profissional
eu continuei trabalhando como consultor
foi uma experiência ótima
até que em determinado momento para
minha surpresa eu tive a oportunidade de
trabalhar numa área de inovação e novos
negócios e lá eles buscavam um perfil
muito específico que eu nunca tinha
planejado para ter mas que por acaso
pela forma que acho que as coisas foram
acontecendo e como eu estava indo
perseguindo meu objetivo
eu acabei no preço por esse caminho que
procuravam uma pessoa que entendesse de
negócio que eu fui para sem planejar
inicialmente uma pessoa também que
tivesse um perfil empreendedor que
tivesse tocado seus projetos que foi a
outra coisa que eu fiz sem planejar
também que foi acontecendo ao longo do
caminho
e lá eu aprendia um método para tocar os
seus projetos para desenvolver os seus
negócios e eu pude enxergar por exemplo
os motivos que eu tinha não os meus
projetos não tinham dado certo
foi muito interessante eu aprendi muito
e é durante esse tempo e aí eu via
durante um durante um almoço com um
amigo
nós vemos uma oportunidade de começar um
negócio com a educação
ele me chamou
a abrir um curso de capacitação de
jovens e basicamente a gente ensina os
começou ensinando os programas de
computação que são mais pedidos no
mercado de trabalho
a gente queria diminuir a distância do
escritório com a pessoa informada que só
pensa em provas está na faculdade foi
muito bom pode aplicar o método que eu
fui aprendendo no meu trabalho desde o
começo a gente começou super pequeno
as primeiras turmas de 15 alunos e foi
muito muito bom foi crescimento
experiência completamente nova para mim
e aí nesse momento o meu objetivo
profissional ficou ainda mais claro eu
queria se empreender
eu queria se empreender com educação mas
além disso quer empreender com educação
para jovens profissionais
eu gostava de ver pessoas que assim como
eu estava começando a carreira estava
estavam buscando o melhor para elas seja
é uma carreira de advogado seja o cara
queria abrir um escrito um negócio
próprio ou o cara queria apenas
conseguir um estágio gostava de ajudar
essas pessoas eu gosto das pessoas isso
com muito claro pra mim e eu vim
desenvolvendo isso com o meu sócio ea
minha equipe durante esses dois anos e
meio na nossa nosso negócio e lá
após alguns algum tempo aproximadamente
dois anos e meio eu conseguir fazer a
transição
eu consegui chegar hoje no meu objetivo
e que não foi planejado mas que hoje é
algo que me faz que eu tenho clareza que
é um objetivo que me deixa muito feliz
então hoje eu empreendam educação para
jovens profissionais me dedico
integralmente é isso essa aqui é uma
foto de uma turma na sala e nesses quase
três anos já foram mais de mil alunos
impactados e aí algumas perdas
algumas pessoas me perguntam e aí que
você pode tirar de aprendizado da sua
trajetória e tudo isso se passou
essas mudanças que você fez na sua
carreira desde o mercado financeiro até
a consultoria até você trabalhar com
novos negócios e abrir seu próprio
negócio já que o tiro duas conclusões
principais a primeira conclusão
não é que você não se apegar aos seus
objetivos iniciais porque as coisas
mudam conforme elas vão acontecendo ea
segunda conclusão gente é pra você não
desprezar as experiências que você pode
ter porque essa experiência ela pode te
abrir um novo caminho no futuro
e aí quando eu olho hoje aonde eu tô eu
penso que é apenas um passo pra onde eu
gostaria de de verdade eu gostaria de
transformar o brasil através da educação
e assim derrubar mais muros que impedem
os jovens de conseguirem os seus sonhos
de atingir seus objetivos profissionais
e aí gente tivesse que deixar uma
mensagem para vocês hoje seria curta sua
jornada
não tenha pressa as coisas boas precisam
de tempo pra funcionar para amadurecer
obrigado
[Aplausos]